well this christmas season many of us
will be staying home instead of
traveling to see family well with the
help of flora couture
you can turn your house into a holiday
home joining us now is michelle
joy howard hey michelle how are you good
jason how are you
fantastic now before we get into
decorating let's talk about your gift
crates they make
gift giving so easy so much fun
so easy great to give we have
all sorts of amazing gift crates that we
can do like this one city
or here or you can do something small
with just fruit
you can do fruit and gourmet you can do
amazing gourmet items we have the
coolest
chocolate who doesn't love chocolate
these are amazing
and some really fun um infused ice cubes
for any of your cocktail mixes
and then some of my favorites are these
amazing teas
now these teas you put these into your
water for your hot water over them
and they actually have a flower bloom
that blossoms out completely
and you can use this multiple times so
so much fun very different
unique different skipped items that you
can give all over the place
but super easy to give because all you
have to do is call us
tell us what you want to send um you can
also go onto our website
and we take care of everything for the
card message including delivery
michelle you do it all over less than 30
seconds you did a wonderful job
decorating our set what real quick what
are some items that we can buy
to create like the perfect holiday home
so the perfect holiday home i'm going to
walk you over here really quickly
you can see above me these amazing
ornaments we have here
in our design showroom and so anything
from your christmas tree decor
to garlands reeves all sorts of things
that you can find
where we will come in and decorate for
you or you can come on in and let us
help you purchase your items and you can
decorate your tree yourself love it
thank you so much michelle we love that
you're locally owned flora couture thank
you so much and rocky let's send it over
to you